so our brains are built out of neurons
and those neurons are fundamentally
similar to the very first evolve neurons
in jellyfish-like or coral like animals
that first emerged about 600 million
years ago and it turns out that neurons
are not that efficient at all they
signal probabilistically they're
unreliable they leak signals to their
neighbors and uh they're slow so then
the question becomes well we're really
clever
we humans uh how do we build clever us
out of such crummy parts and the answer
is that in order to build clever us we
need huge brains we need an
extraordinarily large number of neurons
and to have massive interconnection
between those neurons so we have
something on the order of 500 billion
neurons in the human brain each neuron
receiving about 10,000 connections from
its neighbors now this turns out
actually to be really crucial to our
humanity because our adult human brain
is 1,200 cubic centimeters in volume
that's about three fold larger than an
adult chimpanzee a newborn human has a
brain of volume 400 cubic centimeters
and it turns out as women well know that
that barely fits through the birth canal
as it is it turns out that death during
childbirth is a uniquely human
phenomenon you don't see it in other
animals so you've got a newborn with a
400cc brain an adult with a 1200 cc
brain well it turns out that if you look
at the development of the brain
postnatally there's furious brain
development from birth to age 5 and then
much slower brain development from about
age 5 to 20 and the brain isn't mature
until about age 2
what does this mean it means that humans
have by far the longest childhood of any
animal now what are the sequelae of that
well what it means is that on a Ranga
town mom can take care of her offspring
without any paternal contribution at all
just fine but it turns out if you look
at humans in hunter-gatherer societies
which is what we were up until the last
blink in evolutionary time single
motherhood is not a very viable endeavor
so single moms aren't very effective at
keeping their children alive in
hunter-gatherer societies so that's why
we have cross culturally marriage or
marriage like institutions there isn't a
single culture that has ever been found
that doesn't have something like
marriage the details of the rules can
vary but we all have it why do we have
this when 90% of mammalian species are
promiscuous we're both male and female
have many sexual partners within a given
reproductive cycle we're paternity is
not well established and where the male
does not contribute in any way to the
rearing of offspring why are we so
aberrant it's because our neurons are
lousy processors so we need big fat
brains to make clever us by putting many
of these lousy processors together we
can only get four hundred cc's worth of
these neurons through the birth canal so
we have to have very long postnatal
maturation along childhood and
consequently that's what creates love
that's what creates our cross-cultural
human mating system it comes from the
fact that neurons are lousy processors
you